Okay.
Sicher.
So, wer ist heute Abend dran?
Ja.
Können wir anfangen?
Ja, da sind Sie jetzt. Bitte schön.
Guten Abend, Halle.
Guten Abend.
Brut ist mein Name.
Ich bin die Suchtändige als Sinfonie.
Und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das an einem Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich. Gerne, Frau Doktor. Bitte schön.
Danke. Bevor Sie...
Ja, bitte.
Ich freue mich sehr.
Danke.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre Beschwerden erzählen,
möchte ich einige persönliche Daten erfragen.
Danach werde ich direkt zu Ihren Beschwerdern übergehen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Sieg Fried.
Sieg Fried.
Eberspacher.
Könnten Sie Ihre Nachname bestabilen?
Gerne, natürlich. Eberspacher, das ist Emil,
Bertha, Emil, Richard.
Siegfried.
Bertha, Anton.
Caesar, Heinrich.
Emil, Richard.
Ja, Elbs, Baschach. Richtig?
Eberspacher.
Bachherr.
B-A-S-H.
B-A-C-H-E-R.
E-Bers Bachherr.
Ja, ich habe jetzt verstanden.
Ein schwieriger Name, aber das ist Türkisch-Deutsch.
Ja.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Eberbacher?
Ich bin 60 Jahre alt.
60 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 10. August 1962.
Was machen Sie wirklich, Herr Eberbacher?
Ich arbeite in einer Fabrik, in der Produktion.
Ich bin Maschinenführer.
Und sind Sie vererratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe einen Sohn und eine Tochter.
Okay.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was führt Sie zu uns, Herr Eberbacher?
Ja, vielen Dank, Frau Dr. Bullitz.
Ich habe seit circa 10 Tagen so Schmerzen in meinem Magen,
in der Magengegend.
Und das sticht auch so ein bisschen nach oben in den Brustbereich.
Und ich habe ein bisschen Angst, ob ich vielleicht etwas am Herzen habe.
Ich hatte vor 3 Jahren einen Herzinfarkt und habe 2 Stands bekommen.
Und das macht mir jetzt ein bisschen Sorge und Angst.
Deswegen bin ich heute zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Sie haben schlechte Erfahrungen erlebt.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen ein bisschen beschreiben?
Wie sind diese Schmerzen?
Wie sind die aktuellen Schmerzen?
Ja, die aktuelle Schmerzen und die Schmerzen im Brust.
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, das ist hinter den Brustballen.
Und das sticht auch manchmal so ein bisschen.
Aber manchmal ist es eher so in der Magengegend.
Und da habe ich das Gefühl, das ist wie ein Krampf.
Ein krampfartig Schmerzen haben Sie?
Beide Schmerzen sind schlimmer, wenn Sie sich vorne bogen?
Nein, das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Das kommt und geht.
Es ist von alleine auch mal etwas schlimmer.
Aber dann gibt es auch wieder Phasen.
Da ist es etwas geringer mit den Schmerzen.
Aber ganz weg gehen Sie nicht.
Wie lange dauern diese Schmerzen?
Und wie oft kommen und gehen diese Schmerzen?
Sie haben gesagt, es kommt und geht wieder.
Sie sind durchgehend da in irgendeiner Form.
Aber wie gesagt, es gibt Phasen von 1-2 Stunden.
Da sind Sie ganz heftig mit den Schmerzen.
Und dann gibt es wieder Phasen.
Da ist es etwas besser.
Wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, seit 10 Tagen,
haben Sie anfassartige Schmerzen.
Es kommt ein paar Stunden und geht wieder.
Aber Sie haben einen ganzen Tag diese Schmerzen, oder?
Wir sind eigentlich immer da.
Das ist richtig.
In der Nacht auch?
Dort ist es weniger.
Da kann ich glücklicherweise schlafen.
Aber in den letzten ein paar Tagen
werde ich auch nachts wegen den Schmerzen wach.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzintensität beschreiben?
Wie würden Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben
auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
Wenn null kein Schmerzen,
sind 10 unfertigeregliche Schmerzen.
Also, jetzt in den letzten 2 Tagen
ist es etwas schlimmer geworden.
Da würde ich sagen, so 4 bis 5.
Ansonsten, so weit 2, 3.
Nicht sehr stark wie vorherige
Neokarteinfarktüsse, oder?
Sind diese Schmerzen ähnlich?
Nein, stark sind sie nicht, aber es macht mir Angst,
ob es vielleicht ein Beginn,
vielleicht doch ein Herzinfarkt sein könnte.
Und ich möchte jetzt nicht so lange warten,
bis es ganz schlimm wird.
Ja, ich verstehe aber,
gibt es etwas Bestimmtes,
dass diese Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Nein, nein, also habe ich jetzt nicht gemerkt.
Sehr unterschiedlich.
Und strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinauf?
Also seit heute merke ich,
dass es hier so ringförmig im Oberbauch ein bisschen ist.
Das ist aber erst seit heute.
Und könnten Sie diese Schmerzen betreffen,
wenn Sie sich anders legen,
stehen, sitzen oder vorne bäugen?
Ändert sich nicht, nein.
Und bei der Belastung oder in der Ruhe,
sind diese Schmerzen immer gleich?
Ja, kann man euch schon sagen.
Es ist nicht abhängig von Belastung.
Lassen Sie uns über Ihre allgemeine Körpalee-Funktionen sprechen.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Ja, in den letzten 2-3 Wochen eher wenig, muss ich sagen.
Ich habe jetzt keinen großen Hunger
und habe auch wenig Lust, irgendwas zu essen.
Wegen Schmerzen?
Nein, allgemein.
Kein richtigen Appetit.
In letzter Zeit haben Sie ungewöhnliche Kölle abgenommen?
Nein, also ich bin schon immer sehr schlank.
Ich bin circa 68, manchmal auch 70 kg.
68 Jahre, ich halte das auf Fragen.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,70 m.
Das war immer so?
Sie haben nicht abgenommen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass normalerweise können Sie gut schlafen,
aber nur ein paar Tage können Sie nicht gut schlafen.
Hab ich recht?
Ja, das stimmt.
Wenn Sie mit Verdauungssystem so viel ridden, gibt es etwas Unfalliges.
Ja, Verdauungssystem, meine...
Aus Bedauungssystem?
Ja, akustisch leider nicht verstanden.
Mit dem Verdauungssystem habe ich bisher keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Verstopfung?
Nein, ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich etwas mehr Luft im Bauch
in den letzten Tagen habe, als ich etwas gebläht.
Das Stuhlgang ist normal und Erbrechen habe ich jetzt auch nicht.
Ich habe eine leichte Übelkeit, aber Erbrechen habe ich jetzt nicht.
Und gibt es...
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasser lassen?
Nein, das klappt auch ganz gut.
In letzter Zeit haben Sie etwas Ungewöhnliches gegessen oder getrunken?
Nein, also eigentlich immer das, was ich regelmäßig esse und trinke.
Es war jetzt nichts außer der Reihe oder wir haben auch jetzt nicht auswertig irgendwo gegessen.
Also etwas Besonderes habe ich jetzt nicht.
Und fühlen Sie sich fehlbar?
Nein, fehlbar habe ich jetzt nichts.
Schütteinfluss haben Sie?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Schwiessen Sie in der Nacht?
Nein, nein, habe ich noch nie.
Okay, gut.
Nun würde ich nach Ihren Vorerkrankungen fragen.
Leiden Sie unter irgendwelche chronischen Krankheiten?
Also wie ich schon vorhin berichtet habe, ich hatte vorzuerk...
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie haben zwei Stand.
Genau, aber ansonsten habe ich jetzt keine weiteren Erkrankungen.
Und nehmen Sie Medikamente?
Blutverdünne vielleicht nehmen Sie?
Ja, also das, was wir damals aus der Klinik verschrieben wurden,
das nehme ich auch immer regelmäßig ein.
Das ist das Aspirin.
100, ich habe Raviprin 2,5
und ich habe Amnodipin 5 Milligramm
und ich nehme Pantoprazol 20 Milligramm.
Nehmen Sie Amnidpril und Amnodipin gegen Herzkrankheit
oder haben Sie auch Blutverdünne?
Das hat man mir damals im Krankenhaus verschrieben
nach dem Herzinfarkt und seitdem nehme ich das jetzt.
Und eine Cholesterin Tablette, stimmt, das habe ich jetzt vergessen.
Dann haben Sie auch Hochlippid-Felte?
Also das war auch nach dem Herzinfarkt.
Dann hieß es, ich würde es nehmen und meine Cholesterin sollte niedrig bleiben
und deswegen nehme ich das.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, ich hatte schon mal mehrere Operationen,
aber das waren meistens so Sportunfälle.
Ich hatte mal mich am Knöchel, an der rechten Seite mal,
bei Fußballspielen verletzt, da gab es ein Benderes,
dann ruhte ich am linken Unterarm, operiert,
da bin ich mal bei der Arbeit auf den Arm gefallen.
Und da ist auch eine Platine drin, also ein Metall.
Und das war noch für eine Operation.
Ich hatte einen Leistenbruch auf der rechten Seite,
das ist so circa 10 Jahre her.
Mit wie vielen Jahren hatte sie das?
Vor zehn Jahren.
Sind Sie vollständig gebt?
Ja, da hat mein Hausarzt kontrolliert das immer,
ich bin auch schon geboostet, jetzt gegen Corona,
die anderen Impfen sind komplett.
Ja, gut.
Lassen Sie uns jetzt über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten sprechen,
brauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe vor circa 20 Jahren damit aufgehört, seitdem auch ich das.
Wie viele Jahre und wie oft hat sie geraucht?
Ja, das war so 15 Jahre, habe ich geraucht.
Und das war ungefähr eine Schachtel am Tag.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, eigentlich nicht so ab und zu mal.
Wie meinten Sie mit ab und zu, wie oft?
Ja, das heißt am Wochenende vielleicht,
ein Gläschen Wein und wenn Freunde kommen,
dann trinken wir auch mal gerne ein Bier.
Und haben Sie schon mal Drogen probiert?
Drogen.
Danke.
Ja, Herr Ebbersbauer.
Sind bei Ihren Eltern irgendwelche chronische Krankheit bekannt?
Ja, mein Vater hatte auch mit 70 Jahren mal einen Herzenkrank,
der ist jetzt aber stabile, ist jetzt 85.
Meine Mutter ist leider vor zwei Jahren verstorben,
sie hatte einen Schlaganfang.
Ich weiß nicht, wer leucht.
Mit wie viel Alter ist sie gestorben?
Meine Mutter, die war, als sie starb,
war es 79 Jahre alt.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie zwei Kinder haben.
Sind Ihre Kinder auch gesund?
Ja, glücklicherweise sind sie gesund,
die haben eigentlich keine Probleme.
Herr Ebbersbauer, reagieren Sie auch etwas allergisch?
Ach so, nee.
Also ich bin auf Erdnüsse allergisch,
aber auf Medikamente wüsste ich das jetzt nicht mehr.
Brauchen Sie keine Medikamente.
Wie aussagt sich die Allergie?
Also wenn ich Erdnüsse esse, fällst du dicherweise,
dann kriege ich so richtig Ausschlag am ganzen Körper,
der Mund schwimmt mir an,
bekomme ich schlechtes Luft, ich werde kalt, weiß ich.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie noch Unfälträglichkeiten wie Milchprodukte oder Brot?
Klar.
Alles ok, dann kann ich wirklich alles essen.
Herr Ebbersbauer, ich denke, ich habe die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt.
Jetzt möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder noch etwas fragen?
Nein, vielen Dank, Frau Dr. Flasche, ich habe einfach Angst,
dass es ein Problem mit dem Herzen ist.
Und ich wäre froh, wenn Sie mir helfen können
und mir sagen können, dass es für Beschwerden ist,
woher das kommt.
Ja, ich verstehe, dass Sie Angst haben.
Jetzt können wir leider nicht eine 100%ige sicherer Diagnose sagen.
Um eine richtige und sicherer Diagnose zu bestätigen,
sollten wir ein paar Tests führen
und natürlich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Aber als verdachte Diagnose habe ich Probleme mit Magen.
Aber natürlich hat es früher auch Herzprobleme
und deshalb sollte auch eine Herzkrankheit ausgeschlossen werden.
Sehr gerne, das wäre mir sehr lieb.
Ok, vielen Dank.
Was wollen Sie jetzt für Untersuchungen noch machen?
Natürlich ein EKG, würde ich gerne schreiben.
Ich denke, es gibt ja so eine Blutbild auch durchgesucht werden.
Aber ich denke keine insta- liche Krankheit
und deshalb bin ich mir nicht die Haupt.
Ich brauche Entzündungsparameter oder nicht.
Ich denke, es gibt so eine Kardiac-Enzyme und EKG
und ja, ich möchte Torax.
Sollte durchgeführt werden und je nach Befunde
vielleicht eine Magen-Spiegelung
oder ein Furia-Test vielleicht durchgeführt werden.
Ein Wasfairntest?
Ja, für Helikobacter pluri.
Ah, ok. Was ist das?
Ich glaube, auf türkisch Renefest-Teste.
Aber hier, ich weiß nicht.
Was ist ein Helikobacter?
Ja, das ist die häufigste Ursache für Gastrietes.
Ein Bakterien-Felinfektion.
Das sind Bakterien für die Nage, oder was?
Ja.
Ah, ok.
Das wollen Sie mit der Mannschaft.
Als Differenzialdiagnose,
vielleicht kann ich auch ein Panikattack ausschulissen,
weil der Patient...
meint es sich, ich bin wirklich krank, oder was?
Nie, aber vielleicht diese vorherige Krankheiten können
ein bisschen Angst für sie, Verursachen.
Ach so.
Ja, es kann manchmal passieren,
denn meistens Menschen würde es so gehen in ihrer Lage.
Ja, ich habe natürlich schon Angst.
Deswegen bin ich auch da, ob es vielleicht etwas mit dem Herzen ist.
Aber ich fühle mich jetzt nicht als panisch, oder angstbestmützig.
Ja, natürlich. Ich meine das nicht.
Entschuldige mich dafür.
Ich habe nicht das gemeint.
Aber viele Krankheiten können auch psychische Beschwerden versachen.
Ok.
Ja, gut, vielen Dank.
Dann warten wir mal die Ergebnisse ab von den Untersuchungen.
Ich hoffe, dass wir bald ein Ergebnis finden.
Vielen Dank.
Ich sage gerne.
Ok, bevor Sie jetzt an den Oberarzt oder an die Oberärztin
gehen, möchte ich noch einige Ergebnisse
von den Untersuchungen mitgeben.
Ok. Also, wir haben einen Ultraschall vom Bauch gemacht.
Haben Sie nicht gemacht?
Also, ich habe Oberbauchschmerzen, also Ultraschall.
Leber-Gannenblase ist in Ordnung.
Keine Anzeichen von Entzündung.
Es gibt auch keinen Ganenblasenstein.
Nierenwerte sind, also Nieren sind auch gut.
Leber ist gut.
Es gibt keine freie Flüssigkeit im Bauch.
Es ist ein bisschen Luft überlagert.
Der Milz ist auch normal groß, ist nicht vergrößert.
Und Unterbauch, Handbase und so weiter ist auch alles.
Und Laborparameter?
Genau, Sie machen ein EKG, das ist auch in Ordnung.
Sie machen ein Troponin, das ist negativ.
Im Labor haben Sie eine leichte Leukozytose von 13.000.
Sie haben ein CRP von 30.
Sie haben eine leichte LHT, Gamma GT von 1.100.
GPT und GOTA, also AST, ALT ist unauffällig.
Bilirubin ist unauffällig.
Und das war das kleine Bootbild.
Und das war es erstmal.
Also, ob ich jetzt den Patientin vorstellen kann?
Genau, und wir machen nachher eine Besprechung über die Differenzialiaken.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt, haben Sie Kurzzeit?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen,
den Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Herr Berstbacher ist ein 60-jähriger Patient,
der 8,60 kg, 170 cm ist.
Er hat sich seit 10 Tagen bestehende Epigastrikschmerzen
mit Ringformiga-Erstrahlung vorgestellt.
Er erwähnt, dass diese Schmerzen ansfallartig sein
und ein paar Stunden dauern würden.
Die Schmerz-Interstate sei bei dieser Attacke 4,5.
Und inzwischen 3 bis 3 auf der Schmerzskala.
Es gebe keine Auslöser für diese Schmerzen.
Die Fragen nach Fieber, Schütterfrost und Nachschweiß wurden verneint.
Die Vegetative an einem Nest sei unauffällig.
2-3 Wochen dauern in Appetenz.
Und leichte Neuseer.
An Vorerkrankungen leide er an Herzbranchen.
Er habe Myokartinfarktus vor 2 Jahren gelitten.
Er ließ und dagegen nehme er 100 mg.
2,5 mg. Ramikril, Amnudipin, Pantoprasol und ein Medikament
gegen die Percolastrin.
Er sei vollständig gegen Corona gebt.
Er hatte mehrmals orthopädische Operationen.
Er hatte unter einer HWR-Pilatin einen Knogenbruch.
Er hatte auch eine Operation.
Vor 10 Jahren war er in Gwinal.
Er hatte eine Operation.
Er raufe nicht, aber vor 20 Jahren
habe er mit dem Drauchen aufgehört.
Insgesamt habe er 15 Packungen Rauchkonsum.
Er trinkte nur am Wochenende ein Gläßchenwein.
Er hat seine Mutter wegen Apoplexie gestorben.
Er hat eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Sehr gut.
Er hat eine Herzinfarkt.
Er hat eine Mürkarditis.